good morning everybody thank you so much
for joining me on this wonderful Monday
chika what are you doing you watching
the door for me Oh God everyone everyone
ignore the delivery McDonald's that's
actually extremely old I I have no shame
because yes I ordered delivery
McDonald's but that's ancient also which
reflects badly on me because I don't
take my trash out anyway so don't mind
that this is not this is about this is
this videos a cry for help but it's not
about that I actually have a full music
production suite here stuff that I got
going on and I need your help because I
don't know what I'm doing I've got my
keyboard I've got my interface I've got
my computer with my software on it I've
got this which is broke and apparently
what the hell is going on with that hang
on the keyboard is meant to hook up with
this software set that that allows you
to switch instruments on the fly and do
all this stuff
so what I need from you guys is help on
learning this sort of stuff because as
you know I've been practicing guitar
I've been practicing singing but one of
the things that I want to actually do
because it's another way that I can have
a creative outlet he's actually making
music myself now I don't have everything
because I need my big audio monitors
here I don't have those yet that's my
next purchase that I got to buy but
those are on the way right now but as it
stands I have this software and it's not
like the best of the best I think Pro
Tools is the best but this is this Logic
Pro which is Apple's version of music
production and it's something that I
want to learn just because I want to get
started in some way so if you guys know
anything about music production let me
know down in the comments below tweet at
me some things that you've done if
you've got a music channel on YouTube
dedicated to making music let me know in
whatever way you can because I want to
work with you like I I want to learn as
much as I can because I can fiddle my
way through this and I can get going on
it and I will be getting going on it on
my own but to be perfectly honest I want
help along the way and I want help from
you guys if you guys know what you're
doing then you can help me and we can
work together to try to make some
honestly cool stuff because I'm no
expert at piano but with
like you can make pretty much whatever
you want so that's pretty exciting to me
in other news this is going to be a very
quick vlog we are off to Europe in about
a week we are going to be going to a
bunch of cities all across Europe if you
go to toward markiplier calm what's
going on look at the devastation that
chica has caused she has so many toys
she has spoiled rotten but she just
tears them all apart rips the faces off
of each one kind of like I'm not even
joking about the ripping the faces off
she literally rips the faces off of her
toys and then for this one it's an
especially heinous crime because she
tore the guts out of this toy she's a
vicious horrible beast and likes to
destroy everything that she shoes
isn't that right chica boy that's
absolutely right anyway she's a good
girl but we're gonna be going on tour if
you haven't seen it for yourself go to
tor markiplier comm check out where
we're gonna be going and I'm really
excited about this leg of the tour the
show has gotten so good like tuned in
dialed in we know exactly what we're
doing there's a lot of improv based in
the show so every show is different but
we've gotten to this point where we've
got a really good flow going if you
haven't heard about the show either I
would recommend reading reviews because
there's no better way to tell about a
show than reading what other people have
said about it or hearing what other
people have said about it
it's been nothing but glowing glowing
reviews even people that don't know my
channel that have gone to this show have
enjoyed themselves just because it's
really really fun and I'm not just
Tooting my own horn about it because
it's I'm Tooting the horns of all my
friends because we go out on that stage
together and we rely on each other to
try to be funny for you guys and try to
be entertaining and each show that we do
just shows how much like we've trained
for this we've worked for this and how
well we work together and how much you
guys have fun at the show so if you've
been to a show let us know down in the
comments what you think like what you've
gotten out of it what what to expect out
of it like what kind of fun you had at
the show and if you haven't gotten a
ticket yet please do we're gonna be
coming to Europe and it's going to be a
lot of fun
in other news I've been getting in
shaped like crazy this is just minor
like my life stuff and I don't know how
many people care about my life [ __ ]
um but I've been getting in shape as
hard as I can
I've been doing insanity workouts and I
know this is just vapid I'm not bragging
about this because it's terrible and it
hurts like hell but I've been doing
insanity workouts I've been doing a
strict keto diet I've already lost like
ten pounds in a week and a half I am
getting in the shape of my life for this
tasteful nudes calendar and I will not
be shamed by it I'm a man of my word
even though I set myself up for this I'm
a man of my word anyway all jokes aside
I've been getting in crazy shape and
I've been dieting hard and it's been
really good I feel good I feel motivated
I feel like I'm on track with my life I
feel like I'm settling into a schedule
finally I feel like I have time to
pursue the things that I want to pursue
which is like this music production and
video making and streaming like I've got
everything in order and then this tour
is throwing a wrench in all of that
because then I can't do this stuff right
here because I've got it all nicely set
up here and I can't take it on the road
with me but all that aside it's been so
much fun I've been able to pursue
hobbies of mind that I haven't had been
able to do in a while I've been inspired
to write because I've been reading so
much crap I've been reading books about
the Warhammer 40k universe now I don't
know how many of you guys are fans of
Warhammer 40k or Warhammer in general so
I started with the eisenhorn trilogy
back in fall of last year and right now
I'm reading caiaphas Kain hero of the
Imperium and it's just it's like goddamn
delight and it's so fun I've read like
30 to 40 books in the middle of that
throughout that time and I've read
pretty much every article on the
Wikipedia about Warhammer not the
official Wikipedia entry but their own
wiki just detailing all the different
things about the Warhammer 40k universe
and I'm just like my mind is blown
because if I had soaked in this much
knowledge about music production that I
would already be a savant at it but I'm
not because I'm not that obsess about it
but if you want to debate me on
Warhammer 40k it's been it's already
been a great year like I've been getting
in the shape of my life I've been
pursuing hobbies I've got these new
glasses that you guys seem to like
I really like them my life is going
great I'm having a lot of fun so if you
guys can help me out with this it would
be great help if you know about music
production please let me know about it
let me know samples of what you've made
and also if you want to see like series
on YouTube and stuff like that because I
have to record a lot of stuff before I
leave like this next week is this going
to be a recording slog of just getting
as many videos I can for this next tour
so if you guys want series that you want
to see just let me know down the
comments below write down anything and
everything chances are I've already got
it on a list but there's no harm and you
guys are recommending what you can so
I'll be reading the comments very
intently this particular video so let me
know whatever you got and thanks so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video